bonsoir c'est dans le magnifique manège
du centre hippique du bois de boulogne
que nous nous retrouvons ce soir à côté
de moi un nouveau candidat monsieur
laurent fabius qui sera dans quelques
instants interrogé en littérature et qui
a choisi vous vous en doutez le jumping
comme épreuve sportive ensuite nous
retrouverons monsieur michel de l'or qui
est un cinquième semaine d'un
questionnaire histoire aujourd'hui qui
lui a choisi vous le savez le patinage
de vitesse et pourquoi nous nous
retrouverons à la patinoire fédéral de
boulogne billancourt
je rappelle monsieur michel de l'or n'a
plus de droit à l'échec c'est une
épreuve très difficile pour lui ce soir
revenons à monsieur laurent fabius quel
est votre âge s'il vous plaît j'ai 23
ans vous avez 23
vous êtes parisien et pour autant
actuellement vous faites votre service
militaire mais pas du tout dans l'armée
de terre un mari ou êtes-vous sera selon
à toulon et je crois que vous avez
d'ailleurs eu en 69 une année un petit
peu chargé vous avez passé un certain
nombre de concours d un exam dit nous
sommes un petit peu j'ai passé au mois
de juin l'examen de l'institut d'études
politiques
au mois de juillet une agrégation
lettres et au mois de septembre l'école
nationale d'administration et vous avez
été reçu à tout cela oui j'ai cette
chance
vous avez eu cette chance bien donc
monsieur comme je croise et de règles à
l'ena vous commencez par faire votre
service militaire a besoin de commencer
vos études comprendre et c'est bien cela
la profession de vos parents mon dieu je
crois qu'ils sont anti kir mais je crois
également que ce sont des passionnés de
chevaux que votre frère est également
passionné de cheval nous l'avons
d'ailleurs vu récemment dans un jumping
qui était retransmis depuis nice c'est
bien cela
alors nous allons parler un petit peu
cette épreuve de jumping avant de parler
littérature vous aurez tout à l'heure
dix obstacles à franchir qui nous sommes
en train d'installer d'ailleurs
actuellement dans le manège c'est dix
obstacles au départ seront tous à 1
mètre 20 mai chaque fois que vous faites
une erreur monsieur les obstacles passe
à un mètre 40 alors une erreur il ya un
obstacle à m quarante deux erreurs deux
obstacles etc et pénalités c'est un
obstacle qui change de hauteur qui passe
deux à mettre fin à un mètre carte
monsieur bien sûr vous aurez le droit de
choisir les obstacles c'est-à-dire
supposons que vous ayez cinq pénalités
ce que je ne vous souhaite pas bien sûr
les cinq obstacles qui devront être
monté vous pourrez les choisir bien
entendu monsieur j'espère que ce sera
avec nous jusqu'en quatrième semaine et
à partir de ce moment-là toute façon
vous aurez gagné quelque chose qu'à en
quatrième semaine vous le savez même
s'il vous arrive des malheurs les
compagnies françaises de croisière
maritime et la compagnie générale
transatlantique vous offre pour vous
même et une personne de votre choix des
vacances transatlantique sur le france
ne quitterait pas la marine
vous le voyez et ses vacances comportent
l'aller-retour havre new york séjour de
la new york bien sûr onze jours de
vacances en tout sur le navire amiral de
la marine marchande française monsieur
vous avez choisi la littérature et
j'aimerais vous poser une question bien
sûr c'est ce très vaste sujet quels sont
votre période préférée dirons-nous quel
e siècle par exemple qui me passionne le
plus les auteurs que vous assurer que
comme beaucoup de français c'est le 19e
siècle le 19e siècle et votre siècle
favori et peut-on connaître vos auteurs
favoris et romancé dès 19h les
romanciers du 19e bien monsieur monsieur
fabius pour les trois premières épreuves
aujourd'hui une minute trente chacune
comporte vous le savez cinq questions un
cadeau de notre émission assez adroit à
l'échec j'espère que vous allez en
gagner d'autres
voici cette première épreuve